North Koreans to dance really well too
it's just a different dance you know
they're kind of outdated though because
I saw it and like they're trying to be
modern but they still got like five
accordions and they look like 1963. they
have that no what oh
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
where today we're going part two in on
getting to know Mr Joe Wong here with us
yeah
it's just a lot of pressure on me you
know because I only thought I would I
have one part in my life and that that's
it you know we have a part two yeah yeah
we really want you to make us laugh in
this one oh I think what's what's really
interesting to me is I didn't know that
stand-up comedy was so new in China yeah
and that you guys are a part of a whole
movement to like create a whole art form
and pioneering that space
um I always take stand-up comedy to
being a bit revolutionary and and maybe
even
anti-establishment is it the same in
China where like they're having such
revolutionary thought or like is it is
it that style or is it like old style
comedy where it's like punch after punch
mostly it's old style you know it's like
got it yo mama joke like set up punch
set up yes Jerry Seinfeld you know Jim
Gaffigan you know that kind of I mean
yeah yeah you wasn't it Uncle Roger who
just got banned on social media and
stuff so like you got to be careful
about certain topics are you careful
when you do stand up there I I'm careful
everywhere you know that I mean his
style of Comedy is that's the thing you
know like even even in America is you
can easily offend people you know just
yeah yeah good that's
so here's the thing you know like you
have to be super careful right now yeah
yeah in America basically
there's liberalism but liberalism is
basically within 50 mile radius
metropolitan area yeah it's live outside
of it you know it's very conservative
crowd yeah yeah yeah if you say
something like why privilege you can't
just feel yeah all the [__] say the
room is tied up and suck the air out of
it
diverse part
do you do you change your jokes
depending on
which which crowd you're with oh I do
and I don't you know like with the
Chinese crowds you know I switch a
little bit you know but then uh
but I I kind of yeah
I had some bad experience doing
uh talking about uh racism in America in
in conservative areas really if you talk
about racism in America in China people
don't quite get it you know because they
don't experience it you know racism is a
certain types of racism is a very
American thing yeah oh yeah well that's
true yeah because what's Chinese people
gonna do is
like regionalism
yeah they're like how are you Chinese go
so are you yeah
yeah and also people are very tolerant
about uh racist stuff in China because
they have no idea what that is you know
yeah because sometimes in the English
comedy clubs there was there was
something that's kind of kind of racist
but then the crowd are more across are
more tolerant about it you know it's
because just because they don't quite
get it you know so for them it's just
English that's interesting yeah but but
here oh yeah it's over there like with
the I guess racist or cultural jokes
being more Province based because I
remember growing up my mom would be like
tell me like like this province is known
to be like really stingy this one stinks
this one has rather hot girls they're
like do you do jokes like that about the
different provinces and people kind of
like all on the same page you all get it
well
if you're some people uh both see some
people get it but other people get
offended you know they get the reverse
exactly yeah yeah it's for example you
should joke about certain Province and
then some people from their Province
they get offended you know it happens
before so is that just normal comedy
though oh yeah yeah it's normal comedy
because my mom would tell me like you
can't trust anybody from like Choo Chow
like that
I thought that's true something it's all
but they speak almost like the Taiwanese
dialogue yeah they're made in Cantonese
right I think that's where my
grandparents are from but my mom said
you can't trust anybody that's your
child oh and then she would say
oh yeah I just think that's what that's
a province called that place produces
all the hot chicks I think you're just
saying that that's where you're from
I think the hot chips are from xinjiang
but anyways see I don't know Sichuan
and the problems has hot chicks to be
honest
seriously if you travel over there you
know I just eat that yeah but
then also
people love seeing this stuff but if you
just look at all the pretty actresses
and see where they're from you know it's
all over the place yeah yeah does uh
satire exist in Chinese uh culture oh
yeah yeah oh it's been there but
you know we talk about stand-up comedy
being a big thing now but then before
stand up comedy it was uh crosstalk
that's been popular for you know over
100 years yeah it's kind of like
Vaudeville you know like a variety show
yeah Abba Costello you know two people
oh like
oh like a dual
conversation
yeah yeah yeah Japan had does stuff like
that too yes exactly that was the
dominant form for you know decades it's
like it's like comedy dialogue between
two people like yeah yeah yeah and then
the one person that does a setup and the
other one delivers the punch line yeah
it's like the Takeshi Castle dude yeah
the great thing about that is uh you
gotta build in the audience there you
know you'll see some stuff you know if
the audience doesn't say anything your
partner would go wow haha that's funny
cues the laughter yeah and that's that's
why I used to do uh improv as well I did
that for half a year
improv over there over here uh in in
America yeah but that's because with
improv you have the same thing you know
even if you say something that's kind of
cliche but there's another person there
you know to try to help you out so what
would you do in a product like ground
meat or UCB oh no I did this back in
Boston
so where's your favorite place to do
comedy oh oh there's so many though the
uh the comedy seller in New York
um The Comedy Works in Denver there's so
many great clubs
um what makes a club great oh
low ceilings
um
uh
no uh rear lighting you know it's
basically Spotlight is good oh that
sounds good that's that's about it it
just feels like focused on the jokes and
the comedy yeah yeah do you notice a
difference in crowd like reaction and
participation depending on where you go
oh
um yes
um
if you go to a suburban area basically
ethnic jokes don't go very well
they don't get it yeah not because
they're racist or anything they just
don't understand if they're supposed to
laugh or not
yeah like they're scared to laugh yeah
they were like oh if I laugh at this and
I'm a racist
yeah but if you go to a more
metropolitan area you know racial jokes
just goes really well yeah yeah
it's like you know you're not late you
know every show you you have oh yeah you
know every ethnicity is there it's just
energy is amazing you know that's the
thing about LA and New York you know
this is just the energy is really great
man you do you think you're a bigger
star here or bigger star in China I
don't think I'm I'm big anywhere
yeah
you know it's just
uh this is the thing about comedy you
know when when you're hot people think
you're funny no matter what you say you
know you can't just burp people like Ah
that's the funniest [__] I've ever heard
seriously you know but yeah but if
you're in like nobody knows you you know
you can Crush at night but after the
show people still go to the star that
they know oh yeah so so do you think
familiarity has so much to do with
how they see you already oh
it's huge you know remember uh this
German propagandist said you know if you
repeat a lie a thousand times is the
truth or something
but with the entertainment this is the
same you know just like if you're
familiar face you know even if you're a
shitty act they're still like wow you're
great now they
that's this is how the mind works you
know what helps too is if if somebody
brings someone to the show and they go
yo this Joe guy is hilarious that
they're gonna laugh because they don't
want to look like they were lying yeah
that's why podcasts with comedians did
so well because they could build their
like following and then they have inside
jokes and then now when when they're not
even auditioning at the show anymore
people are coming to see them because
they just like you that's uh that's a
great point and also
uh
when you're at a comedy club especially
in some uh not so great shows
you have like 20 comedians in the lineup
and three audience members there oh it's
like you hear something funny but you're
like oh nobody else is laughing yeah you
don't want to be the loudest guy yeah if
I laugh at the wrong joke and these two
are gonna know who who left you know but
if it's a packed room it's okay you know
there's so many people even if you laugh
them wrong [__] but people know nobody
knows who did it
do you have a podcast oh yeah I I just
started one yeah it's called a a stand
up with our borders and a an interview
stand-up comedians from different
countries but also I interview people
who are not comedians but they have a
very interesting point of view you know
a recently I just interviewed this uh
fashion designer called Kiki and the
weird thing about her is um
she's a fashion designer she doesn't
know how to make clothes what she
doesn't know how to draw pictures of her
good good clothing that she makes sounds
about where she wants to get made like
make a dress like this
someone has to be like okay I gotcha but
you're very close
yes and you she writes books but she
just tells me people shouldn't be
reading books you know you should do
your own thinking
she's just like wow that's such a fine
that kind of character character is very
interesting that's why you interview
them walking contradiction oh yeah I
know I know I'm still like how the [__]
does she design fashion oh yeah but but
she's a business woman so she had runs a
company she just caught she knows uh who
can do this job she'll tell them oh I
want a you know dragon in this part of
the robe or something and they just do
it for her and
she did the clothing for you know like
um Miss Marvel or something
and uh she was designing clothes for uh
con film festival and stuff wow yeah you
know just people have wow very
interesting career paths yeah that's
crazy yeah that's that's why I wanted to
do this uh podcast
also you know the comedy change too you
know we spoke about influencers
you know I don't know if you know this
comedian called uh joyin yeah Summers
yeah exactly oh yeah yeah if you're all
telling you about her she has a big
accident too oh yeah I think accent and
plus you know when I first met her we
met in China she wanted to become an
actress in Hollywood but but then you
know for one reason or another people
thought her accent was too thick no
yeah to think even for fresh off the
boat you know that's your real accent
accent
uh so she decides to become a stand-up
comedian you know for me if a guy like
me I just basically grind it out in
comedy clubs yeah but for her she
couldn't even do that because of the
pandemic
so she just did it she actually just
purchased the Comedy Club on Hollywood
on Melrose she purchased it yeah just
she bought the comedy club just does it
and then maybe she's doing it for
passion enough I know sure was she a
biotech person too yeah how does she
have all that money wait yeah exactly
why do you think Bob that person can
afford to buy a club
dresses yeah so and then the pandemic
has so the way she does it she just
taped herself doing stand-up comedy with
no audience puts it online and see how
people respond to it
and eventually after a couple of years
she actually built the following online
wow and has a set of uh jokes if she can
do her special lesson she can tour with
wow what still made it happen yeah
Amazing Story I I was like Wow because
you know like traditional comedians
would hate these type of you know
influencers because they want everyone
to grind the way they are yeah yeah of
course you know but then
and I was like yeah but that's a
different grind though yeah it's a
different grind yeah you think about
putting out you know uh short videos day
after day you know it's just yeah and
she has cats you know just in her videos
where she's like doing stand-up with no
audience is she like editing an audience
laughter Oh I I don't know the details
yeah I'll be like that's brilliant yeah
yeah do you think there'll ever be a
time where like there's
after school comedy clubs for kids but
like in China
's usually like piano or like oh yeah
yeah very traditional like Asian
extracurricular stuff you think you
think it'll ever get it like I I don't
know I don't know if it's gonna reach
that point but it's possible in a major
city still like there used to be like
the I spoke about crosstalk right yeah
they actually groom their apprentices
since they were like five or six years
old
you live in your Master's house that's
old school whoa Super old school but
there's still Stars uh crosstalk stars
who started like that whoa why do they
need them that young oh they just to
help have that conversation already oh
yeah they they can perform on stage are
they young oh I see yeah yeah and
basically the master is tell us tell us
you'll see this and the audience gonna
laugh when you say this word it's very
specific you know and that's how they
learn the the trade yeah that's really
old school because old um theater that's
how they formed a lot of groups in Asia
like they started they it's like you
know how the K-pop like
performance groups from from kids it's
like that like a lot of performance
theater yeah they're like training
system yeah yeah that's like an old
school art yeah but I have to say these
K-Pop Stars
you know
they were so disciplined you know I was
really impressed when I was in China
sometimes I would do certain uh La
variety show or whatever
they they always sit in a really good
posture you know it's just like uh they
stay up late no one complains nobody
takes a nap or anything I was like wow
how can they do this you know it's just
wow it's amazing you know they're
they're work ethic it's just astounding
you know yeah it's like North Korea
focused on The Military and South Korea
focused on K-POP same approach for
discipline oh but one went makeup and
dance exactly
yeah but then you know the
North Koreans to dance really well too
it's just a different dance you know
they're kind of outdated though because
I saw it and like they're trying to be
modern but they still got like five
accordions and they look like 1963. they
have that no what oh North Korean Dance
dances in oh you can see them in China
though if you go to certain restaurants
oh yeah yeah they were like North Korean
uh performance Hoops yeah they're they
have like 10 accordions
no literally it's it's like that's I'm
not even joking it's like 10 late
accordions singing and it's all Corey oh
yeah yeah and are they all hungry
they're starting now they're well fed
they're well fed yeah they're I think I
think because they're the performance
ones they're actually they're not gonna
send out the hungry ones yeah I thought
they're just like dancing on people's
tables and then just like
a piece
what's that
the North Korean
that you can go to and they yeah they
serve North Korean food they have the
performances and it's all North Korean
workers wow yeah so you could get the
North Korean experience it's like a
dinner and a show the whole experience
well this video seems to be ending isn't
it
seems to be ending
[Music]
foreign